this video is brought to you by bright
sellers
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here walt
disney world in my beloved home state of
florida is not just a theme park
spanning over 40 square miles it's
roughly the size of san francisco
sure it's got cool rides but there's
also massive hotels campgrounds
a baseball stadium multiple shopping
complexes and golf courses
a few privileged people even live on the
property
some in fancy houses custom designed
with hidden mickeys
for the rest of us a short drive through
one of the entrance arches brings us
into a realm where birds can talk
princesses are real and mexico norway
and china are a short stroll from each
other for a pretty hefty fee
visitors can get a few days of magic and
extremely clean bathrooms
many disney devotees think this
consumer's utopia is worth the price
and some even dream of one day owning a
multi-million dollar home in the magic
kingdom's backyard
but what if i told you there was an even
greater cost to experiencing disney's
magic
your freedom oh okay not exactly but
while disney world is the most magical
place on earth it does some things to
achieve that magic that raised some
pretty interesting concerns about the
relation between
magic and freedom and maybe even
nightmarish technologies of control
and i'm not talking about that weird
pandemic reopening ad
so what gives disney world its magic
please remain seated with your hands
arms and legs inside the vehicle while
we find out in this wisecrack edition
on disney world but before we get into
it i want to give a shout out to this
week's sponsor bright sellers
bright cellars is a monthly wine club
that matches you with wine that you will
love
you simply take a six question quiz and
then the bright sellers wine
connoisseurs will whip up
recommendations for your tasting
pleasure
oh and don't worry the quiz is really
simple you don't need any prior wine
knowledge the questions include easy
stuff like juice chocolate or tea
preference
it'll then select a handful of
recommendations that are best suited for
your palette
if you like them and are over the legal
drinking age you can have them shipped
straight to your door
i love that each bottle comes with a
wine education card which includes
tasting notes like how to pair the line
or
what temperature it needs to be served
at it takes the snobbery out of wine
tasting and makes for a great date night
if that sounds like a chill time then
you should check it out right now they
are offering
50 off your first six bottle wine box
but only if you hit the link in the
description
so go on and treat yourself now back to
the show
whenever anyone talks about their love
of disney world they almost
always mention how magical it is pretty
much every disney and vacation blog has
some listicle describing how the florida
resort has a special brand of magic that
keeps people coming back for more they
usually praise the attention to detail
and theatrics things like
background music lighting and
stormtroopers who wander around and
interrogate children
some mention the pristine and punctual
transportation systems
many love the total immersion that cuts
one off from the outside world
there's a word for places where the
monorails run on time and
music bellows from fake rocks
heterotopia
coined by philosopher michel foucault in
1967 heterotopias are real
places that mirror society but are
somehow completely different than
other or as foco puts it places that are
written into the institution of society
itself where
all the other real emplacements that can
be found within culture
are simultaneously represented contested
and inverted
what does that even mean for foucault
heterotopias are places that look a lot
like our world but feel different
mirroring aspects of it but with a
something's quite not
realness about places like polynesian
vacation villages
that fake rainforest in the middle of
the zoo big hollywood movie sets and of
course
disney i mean when you enter the magic
kingdom you literally walk down a fake
recreation of a timeless american main
street complete with a trolley car and a
barbershop quartet why go there when you
can just visit a real charming small
town
because for whatever reason something
about it seems better
magical in heterotopias familiar things
are taken from their original contacts
and repackaged so that we no longer
think about or
even understand how they work at disney
world everything around you is both real
and fake at the same time to the point
where you can no longer tell which is
which and you kind of don't care an
ultimate suspension of disbelief trash
cans could talk
mount everest is in florida and it's
normal to spend seven
bucks on a pretzel this might sound kind
of harmless
but creators of heterotopias have to do
a ton of meticulous architectural
planning to pull them off in order to
keep tight control over the experience
and
disney sure knows something about
control to understand what makes disney
world such a successful heterotopia and
how it functions it's important to
understand the
modestly terrifying thing it was
supposed to be in the final years of his
life walt disney was frustrated with the
result of his biggest
project disneyland the park was great
and all but cheap motels and tourist
traps were springing up in the outskirts
of his immaculate theme park and he
couldn't do anything but build a
fence to protect his wholesome family
fun so the og mouseketeer set his sights
on a new project
not just a second disneyland no it would
be a whole
freaking world tomorrow a project so
vast
it has already been called a whole new
disney world
he bought 27 000 acres of land in
central florida with all of this new
land strip malls couldn't spring up a
stone's throw from the park exit
so one thing we don't need is a fence to
protect us from trespassing
visitors wouldn't have to look at ugly
neon signs or
witness drunk teenagers everything
within miles of the park would be
planned and approved by disney he wanted
complete control over what
surrounded his theme park too and with
all this land
walt disney had even loftier ambitions
another way he could leave his mark on
florida and
on america born from a new dedication to
solving the plight of america's
cities i don't believe there's a
challenge anywhere in the world that's
more important
to people everywhere than finding
solutions to the problems of our cities
yes that's right walt disney wanted to
build an entire futuristic city on his
newly acquired land
an experimental prototype city of
tomorrow
epcot possible today with the technology
and imagination
of american industry disney felt the
best way to address
urban problems like poverty and crime
and grungy bars
wasn't to try and help existing cities
it was to build an entirely new city
that didn't
have those things and build it from
scratch on private property
we think the need is for starting from
scratch on virgin land
and building a special kind of new
community walt's grand vision was
heavily inspired by an architect named
victor gruen you might not know his name
but you'll probably recognize his work
brewing created america's first shopping
malls and
lots of them ironically brewing was a
socialist who envisioned
malls not as pure commercial enterprises
but as mixed use civic spaces to combine
consumer activities with humanistic
value so uh
how'd that work out i love
the smell of commerce in the morning in
his final years
gruen started fighting against the
construction of shopping malls his
vision a massive
failure corrupted by greed the mall was
far less a civic space and far more a
place for blind consumption
a book by gruen sat on walt disney's
desk as he planned his new world it
outlined a circular three-dimensional
urban design with a completely
pedestrianized city center that had a
mix of commercial and functional use
where no cars were allowed
disney also promised in epcot there will
be no slum areas because we won't let
them develop
people will rent homes instead of buying
them and that modest rental there will
be no
retirees everyone must be employed so
sorry grandma you can't come unless you
work until you drop dead
i don't make the rules i just ride it's
a small world five times a day
using this pitch for a grandiose utopia
where everyone had a job
disney got buy-in from the state of
florida before he had any solid plans
for how he'd
actually achieve it it was also supposed
to be housed in a 50-foot climate
control bubble which
i just needed to fit in here somewhere
anyway florida approved the creation of
a unique local government spanning
two newly formed municipalities the
corporation would get the incredible
powers of self-government the following
year
although the amount of control disney
was given was unprecedented the idea
wasn't entirely new it was just the
latest version of a
company town in america and europe
company towns were places where one
company owned literally
everything housing businesses schools
even churches
if you lived in the town you had exactly
one employer to choose from
worse your employers wouldn't even pay
you real money for you to save up and
move somewhere else they were paid in
scripp
which is like 19th century v bucks that
you could only spend at company stores
comedy towns in the us were
characterized by industrial paternalism
a kind of social engineering that forces
middle class values onto working class
employees
it basically meant the companies that
ran these towns imposed a ton of rules
on its residents like banning gambling
drinking and
unions many founders of company towns
framed this as a moral obligation they
were teaching
lower class workers good values and
providing them a life
in a model community in exchange for
their labor they indoctrinated people
with company loyalty all the while
keeping workers indentured to their jobs
and towns for
incredibly low pay sometimes their
housing would even be fenced in or
guarded they
literally couldn't leave while comedy
towns were very popular during the
industrial revolution they declined in
america in the 1920s because
among other things workers living
conditions deteriorated and you know
they weren't allowed to vote or change
anything
leading to massive strikes and riots
while old school comedy towns were out
of vogue by the time of epcot disney's
paternalistic vision for it was eerily
similar if not more ambitious
his only major deviation from
traditional company town ideals
while everything would be owned and
operated by disney epcot would also rent
building space to local industrial
leaders like general
electric and have expos sponsored by big
corporations showing off the newest
technology and while people would earn
real money instead of script there would
be plenty of ways to give that money
right back to disney after walt's death
his brother roy took over to carry out
the vision and
the reedy creek improvement district was
formed disney can now design
and maintain its own infrastructure
projects enforce its own zoning and
building codes maintain its own police
force and fire department and levy taxes
it would be entirely governed by its
landowners which you know is pretty much
just
disney governing officials would be
chosen by landowners again
basically just disney because who needs
a mayor when you have a benevolent
multinational corporation looking after
you
right couple that with disney's public
aversion to drinking
no alcohol was allowed in the magic
kingdom until 2012 as well as his
antagonism towards unions and aggressive
promotion of mid-century middle class
nuclear family values
and you've got the makings of the most
ambitious company town
in history too ambitious because the
city of tomorrow
never actually happened after imagineers
realized they couldn't figure out who
would live there or how kids would go to
school or how families would actually
function the plan was scrapped epcot
became another very clean theme park
with very good crowd control and much
like gruen's ill-fated shopping malls a
place for consumers to give away all
their cash which you know
disney is still pretty stoked on okay
okay so
what does the disney world that didn't
happen have to do with the disney world
that did the one where you can wait for
three hours in the sweltering florida
heat to go
on the avatar ride disney world might
have lost its city but it never
lost its powers of self-governance it's
basically the american equivalent of the
vatican and its doctrines still consist
of walt's paternalistic values and a
philosophy that requires both corporate
sponsorship
and meticulous design and control of
well
everything i mean look at their queuing
systems in travels and hyper reality
umberto echo describes how the officials
of the dream properly dressed in the
uniform suited to each specific
attraction
not only admit the visitor to the
threshold of the chosen sector but in
successive phases
regulate his every move if the visitor
pays this price he can have not only
the real thing but the abundance of the
reconstructed truth when you're waiting
in line to go to the haunted mansion
you're not in a line you're in a
graveyard and then you're escorted by a
spooky maid into a foyer and then an
elevator
and then another inside line that's
supposed to be a
living room maybe but really you're
flowing through carefully crafted crowd
control that is meant to be
invisible the point is everything at
disney world is calculated to control
your experience
from the sewage system to tiny details
at the bottom of a man-made hot spring i
mean
911 they were able to efficiently
evacuate approximately hundreds of
thousands of people could you imagine
san francisco doing that
it's no wonder people take out a second
mortgage on their house so they can fly
across the world to visit this place
not only can you meet mickey and his
pals the whole experience feels unlike
anything else on our planet
so immersive that even though there's no
giant bubble dome over the place
there might as well be because of all of
the surrounding land disney owns
you're literal miles away from the real
world you'll never see garbage cans
overflowing or even emptied because the
trash is whisked away underground
at 60 miles per hour there are no
telephone poles or wires obstructing any
views
you can visit convincing versions of
real countries without leaving the us
but everyone speaks english and all the
streets are so clean
everyone is happy and friendly and has
the same
three hairstyles but peek beneath the
shiny perfect service and it becomes
clear that there's something else going
on in order to maintain its heterotopic
status
the most magical place on earth doesn't
just hide its sanitation workers and
trick you into enjoying your hour-long
wait
it also hides all the things that plague
us out in the real world
creating a space grounded in walt
disney's paternalistic corporatist value
system
anthropologist stephen feldman calls it
dystory he argues that
these theme parks conveniently censor
those aspects of u.s history that
conflict with white anglo-saxon
protestant middle class values and
behaviors
these theme parks portray one vast
vanilla flavored american melting pot
that
never existed and it makes people feel
good i mean
i get it a liberty square that included
the triangle shirtwaist factory fire
where women burned alive after their
bosses locked them inside might not be
the most magical experience
instead imagine a world where all the
things we've done didn't exist and
freedom is sponsored by american express
and coca-cola
imagine a china that doesn't mention the
words people's republic or communism
disney by its very nature has to hide
all the ugliness that makes it so
magical
in the first place sure there's no
inkling of poverty
anywhere on the 47 mile property because
of extensive surveillance policing and
enforcement of private property laws
disney does its own safety inspections
on all of its rides off property many of
disney's minimum wage employees commute
in
every day from far less manicured areas
you have to go through private security
and ticket tag users
even have to scan their fingerprints to
enter no
unscrupulous behavior is tolerated
either if you pull any drunken antics or
break a law
even a minor misdemeanor you don't just
get a court date in a fine
you can be banned for life and thank god
i'm not banned from disney for life just
universal studios and all their
associated properties these are
all things that most folks in america
would never tolerate from their own
government i mean think about how many
people
flipped after airports started asking
for bio data but because of a meticulous
effort to create a consumer's utopia
unaffected by the ills of the outside
world people will gladly give up their
privacy
and their cash to experience that
special disney magic
disney is also so good at indoctrinating
people because the brand has essentially
conquered contemporary life
disney has its hand in almost every
piece of popular culture in existence
and their ideology is super palatable
it's wholesome
family-friendly magic you're getting
here mickey can't hurt you
there seems to be a limit for people's
tolerance for this magic though
in 1994 disney tried again to make a
planned community
celebration florida was modeled much in
that victor grew in style of urbanism
small pedestrian friendly downtown areas
and plenty of public space it would have
schools built within the community for
residents to send their kids
community fitness centers places of
worship playgrounds and theaters like
everything else disney builds
celebration was meticulously designed
down to its manhole covers there was a
complete ban
on franchises and billboards but what
disney called an authentic small town
america experience
didn't feel so authentic chalk it up to
the fake snow if you want or the
loudspeakers hidden behind palm trees
that pumped out music but it was creepy
and void of character
there were no gas stations or
restaurants only disney stores according
to a former resident
a cuban immigrant who loved disney
decided not to buy a house there because
its sterility reminded him too much
of communist cuba the over engineering
and disney focation of celebration
also made people paranoid were the
alligators in the man-made lake put
there for show
is the fake snow even actually fake snow
what other fake things
aren't the fake things we think they are
celebrations soon started to suffer from
the kinds of problems many suburbs in
florida suffered from
an economic recession caused a ton of
home foreclosures
when it was first announced demand to
live here was so high disney ran a
lottery
bill and susan bona were among the first
400 winners
i think people came here because
thinking they were going to be living on
main street usa and you know the pixie
dust would be sprinkled and their life
would be perfect and
they wanted the monorail to pick them up
at their front door and you know it's
this is
real life real mortgages real jobs
there was a brutal murder and a suicide
people started accusing disney of being
more focused on corporate needs than the
needs of its residents
for the first time it seemed that disney
had lost control
so instead of trying to address the
problems of celebration disney sold it
to private investors and then did what
disney does best
started again from scratch in 2011
disney built another community on its
property called
golden oak owned by people like the
former ceo of walmart homes start at 2
million like the rest of disney the
community is planned and controlled
doors must be made out of wood and trash
is hidden in a designated area there are
several man-made lakes and a river and
fake scents are pumped into the country
clubhouse
obviously this isn't the robust planned
community walt intended it's not
providing
anyone with jobs there are plenty of
retirees and it pretty much
exclusively caters to the very wealthy
even if you can't afford the 2 million
mansion there's no denying that disney
is a fun escape from reality it's
supposed to be fun it is very
good at being fun but the reason why
it's so good of being fun
is because of an amount of tight
paternalistic control that some might
call
creepy others might say it gets awfully
close to a kind of
corporate fascism where freedom is
traded in for clean streets and the
obliteration of social problems the
heterotopia of disney world
tricks us into thinking we're
experiencing magic but
like any other heterotopia disney and
all its strangeness
also reveals a whole lot about the real
world it desperately tries to hide it
reveals the values and priorities of our
own society
but what do you think is disney the only
reprieve from our hell world
should we consider ourselves lucky to
live in teslaville where elon musk is
dictator for life
let us know in the comments as always
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support
hit that subscribe button while you're
waiting in line for a gargantuan turkey
leg and don't forget to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you